[Musique]
le 9 juin prochain les salles de sport
pourront de nouveau accueillir du public
un public qui aura peut-être déjà pris
goût à l'effort en plein air on attend
dans les salles de sport on peut
toujours jouer au tennis en extérieur
par exemple ou exemple mais roland
garros c'est malheureusement le reflet
du niveau actuel du tennis français oui
trois bleus qualifiés seulement dans le
tableau masculin ici à roland garros et
le pire bilan depuis 1968 alors c'est
vrai chaque année parce que c'est roland
garros on s'enflamme on attend des
miracles du tennis français mais le
constat est dur parce qu'à roland garros
la seule chose encore plus battu que la
terre ce sont les français voilà le
genre de commentaire on peut lire ça ce
début de tournoi catastrophique pour les
tricolores
je soutiens pas supporte parce que je
déteste le mot supporte je soutiens
l'équipe de france bravo chassé de la
traduction d'une banale deux se portent
ces six sigma pourquoi on dit ça
maintenant
avant on attendait la deuxième semaine
pour voir les français disparaître
maintenant c'est au bout de deux jours
diane internautes on en est au stade où
je crois plus aux chances françaises
pour le prochain euro visions ajoute un
autre
et je laisse aux téléspectateurs la
bonne interprète aussi porté vilain mot
de même que on dit on ne parle plus de
défis on parle de challenge c'est
totalement idiot il y avait dieu sait
qu'ils appellent le défi oui on peut
dire challenge également à l'anglais
c'était francisé bon c'est ça vient de
l'ancien français en fait challenge avec
un seul l et c'était une attaque un défi
parfois la france insoumise et un peu
ambigu sur l'antisémitisme et paraît
parfois bout des doigts rien madame ben
je ne sais pas
donnez moi un exemple parce que moi je
pense au bout de dix recommandations
n'ont sûrement j'accepte voir
l'antisémitisme fois il ya des
ambiguïtés dans madame ce n'est pas vrai
débat juridique c'est vrai ne m'habite
et plus jamais syrie par ne méritait pas
avec ça moi je suis pas ambiguë
marc bellemare ni bike tour le lieu
riche femme que no man ou six autres
[Musique]
il se plante là bas maintenant il
revient pour faire quoi
comme le dit joël essaie de trouver un
nouveau finaux un nouveau truc c'est ce
qui va se passer
non moi ce qui me cramer la sq il est
pas un peu réveillé ma femme et moi je
veux bien tout ce qu'on veut mais enfin
si voilà je reconnais l'intelligence de
l'homme c'est pas là il ya aucun
problème c'est pas ce que je pense que
ce n'est pas une mauvaise personne du
tout manuel valls la question n'est pas
là mais politiquement revenir ici mais
finir il est cramé la caricature est la
fois cruel et justes et quand tu y as du
talent il faut toujours le le
reconnaître utilisez une méchanceté sur
monsieur klarsfeld le castaldi je dire
c'est prouvé le ces infâmes on joue pas
avec l'antisémitisme merde moi j'ai
région tronchon excusez moi madame vous
pouvez nous reprocher des choses mais
pas ça moi j'accepte pas ou alors si
céline si vous pensez ça ne me tentait
plus jamais si la merde
en fait nous les meufs on est trop fort
pour détourner les mecs vous êtes des
imbéciles je suis désolé qu une meuf qui
veut arriver à ses fins elle a plus de
chances que ben non je suis pas daccord
jours mais d'abord je suis papa collage
fait d'abord si vous sortez avec des
tenues en fait tu voyages
moi je pense qu'anastasia que je pense
qu'avec keynes et tout acquis tout à qui
ça veut dire quoi c'est plein de
français elle est en phase terminale
dans vingt ans nous aurons nous
parlerons plus le français que nous
avons parlé vous savez très bien le
franglais a tout envahi
c'est invraisemblable et ce franglais
attaques non seulement les mots pourquoi
les clusters pourquoi employer le mot
cluster vos foyers pourquoi click and
collect c'était plutôt avec celle en
fait lui des vidéos chill qu'est ce que
c'est pour nous les jeunes jeux couverts
si ça va être un peu à décontract vous
le posez pour toi les jeunes est pour
beaucoup de gens m'avaient as existe
depuis très longtemps and style cool de
contracter c'est la même chose
imaginez-vous c'est cette dépravation
on a appelé la sorbonne sorbonne
universités qui est de l'anglais mission
dans tous les domaines
oui mais ça c'est l'éducation nationale
s'est mise de la culture c'est le
président de la république c'est
l'ensemble albert einstein 162 q nicolas
copernic 132 qi wolfgang amadeus mozart
150 ils ont révolutionné le monde et
repousser les limites du cerveau mais
ils ne sont rien à côté d'eux
diarra ou 180 depuis 1988 en france
sachez qu on est autour de 98 voilà la
moyenne elle autour de sang voilà 98 toi
là il aurait donc accueilli près de deux
fois supérieur à la moyenne
ben franchement j'ai un petit problème
il n'arrive pas à capter comment on
comprend dés de tomate dct voir passer à
l'horizon entre ciel bleu et mer azur un
écran publicitaire de 32 mètres carrés
ce n'est pas du goût de tout le monde
c'est moche et nietzsche je trouve ça
dommage on est toutes ensemble à l'écran
une fois qu'on a la plage au bord de mer
il ya encore un écran géant au magazine
que tu regardes nouveau gros coup pour
coup les écrans et moi en fait tu vois
d'autres au cerveau il ya des petits
comme des copains qui tiennent les mains
tu vois quand ils se tiennent les mains
et ils sont tous copains mais si tu
regarde beaucoup la télé à tes copains
ils pourront plus tenir les mains et
donc tu va réfléchir beaucoup invite ont
beaucoup moins bien mais non c'est pas à
moi en allemand c'est quoi c'est le tub
pub sais c'est pas un mot allemand
excusez moi vous m'avez vu souvent dire
tob le fera une fois oui mais c'était
pour parler de quoi
ah non c'était lors d'une question on
avait une question tub
oui oui on avait surtout vous êtes sûr
vous étiez sur la bonne chère lui s'est
dit dès le début je vais les défier du
regard je ne rigolerai pas à leurs
conneries c'est vrai je trouve que ça
nous sert à énormément de ce qu'on nous
ressort la vidéo tout le tort et que du
coup il est toujours cette même tête de
gland de regarder en nous fixant comme
ça du regard et c'est assez ridicule f k
oui mathilde tête de gland bas on voit
non quand même pas alors notre
rédactrice en chef la qui tient quand
même à son rôle de mère de famille me
dit non non ça me rappelle rien pendant
une question à base de à base de
le récipient dans lequel autrefois ça ne
pas l'être venir ça sape une pub à tête
mais on a encore le droit de poser une
question parce que c'est fini bah oui